a couple of uh tricks uh when you're
writing um I find it's very bad to write
in final draft or in a document because
you can see what you're writing and
you're thinking to yourself oh God it's
garbage it's garbage and you lose all
your confidence so try this trick where
you take a little dictaphone or a
handheld recorder and you speak out your
scripts into it you can't see the words
also you can't turn back it's linear and
so what you actually have to do is it
forces you to just get a vomit draft out
and you accept because this is a vomit
draft it's going to be stinky that's
fine no big deal so your dialogue will
all sound the same because you're
talking that way and your scene
descriptions will not be eloquent
because you talk them out but you're
going to get impeccable pacing because
your body knows how to Pace a movie
because you've sat in front of so many
movies and so then you can click into
that other side of your brain this is no
good brain and start empirically editing
that thing um and that's a nice little
trick for me